- So by now you've probably seen
the harrowing footage of
Daunte Wright being shot
in what was supposed to
be a routine traffic stop.
And reports are that one of
the officers on the scene
intended to draw a taser but
instead drew her service weapon
and shot Daunte Wright in the chest.
- [Woman] Taser, taser, taser!
- Now, many people have
suggested that this officer
could be charged with
involuntary manslaughter
and that could fit but
this has happened before.
In New Hope, Pennsylvania, an
officer shot an unarmed man
in a holding cell thinking
that he was pulling his taser.
The man survived and the district attorney
didn't press any charges.
Though in two other cases
in Oakland, California,
and Tulsa, Oklahoma where the
police officers drew a gun
instead of a taser, they were convicted
of killing the victims in those cases.
So we'll see what happens
in this particular case.
It's a tragedy either way.